عوده الى خبر استهداف في مطار دمشق الدولي
في اول يوم تولى لتنياهو سلطه في اسرائيل
مجددا بقدر ما قد يؤكد الهجوم اولويات
نتنياهو المبكره يرسخ ايضا استمرارا ما
تسبه اسرائيل خيار التصدي لمحاوله ايران
تعزيز وجودها العسكري في سوريا القصف
الاسرائيلي الجديد اخرج المطار الرئيسي
والاكبر في سوريا من الخدمه عده ساعات كما
خلف اربعه قتلى واضرارا في مستودع للاسلحه
وكذلك بعض المنشات هذا ذلك الى توجيهي عدد
من الرحلات نحو مطار اللاذقيه شمالا قبل
استئناف في حركه الملاحه في مطار دمشق
واصلاح احد المدرجين اللذين تعطل جر هذا
القصف هذه المره الثانيه التي يتوقف فيها
مطار دمشق عن العمل منذ يونيو الماضي حين
ادى قصر الاسرائيلي الذات الى تعليق كل
الرحلات مده اسبوعين تقريبا بعد ما الح اه
اضرار كبيره باحد المدرجات وفي نوفمبر
الماضي استهدف قصف الاسرائيلي مطار
الشعيرات العسكري في وسط سوريا ادى ايضا
الى مقتل عسكريين اثنين وجرحه اخرين وفي
سبتمبر ايضا قصفت اسرائيل المره الثانيه
على التوالي خلال اسبوع مطار حلب ما ادى
الى خروجه عن الخدمه
لثلاثه ايام كما شلت اسرائيل في اغسطس
الماضي هجمات على طرطوس بينما تعتبر دمشق
ومحيطها اكثر المناطق استهدفا خلال
السنوات الماضيه وفي فبراير عام 2022
تعرضت مواقع في محيط مدينه القنيطره قرب
الجداد المحتل لقصف الاسرائيلي واجمالا
شنته اسرائيل خلال سنوات الماضيه عشرات
الهجمات على سوريا لكنها ظلت دون اي رد
حتى هذا اليوم
استهداف الاراضي السوريه المتوسطه
عام 2013 تتجنب اسرائيل تبانيه على نيه
لكن بعض مسؤوليها اقروا به في نهايه عام
2022 اقر الجيش الاسرائيلي في بيان
بمهاجمه مئات الاهداف في سوريا شملت مواقع
ايرانيه والشحنات اسلحه مواجهه الى حزب
الله اللبنانيين في اوائل سبتمبر الماضي
قال رئيس لجنه الخارجيه والامن فليكريست
الاسرائيلي ران بن مبارك ان اسرائيل
مسؤوله عن قصف مطار حلب والهدف ايصال
رساله للرئيس السوري في يناير عام 2019
اكد رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيابه سنه
طيران الاسرائيلي غاره على مخازن اسلحه
قال انها ايرانيه قرب بطاريه دمشق وبعد
ذلك باسبوع وقال رئيس اركان الاسرائيلي
انا ذاكر
جنرالذيكم ان اسرائيل ضربت الاف الاهداف
الاي في سوريا منذ دون ان تعلن عن ذلك